welcome to another episode of from
learning hope you're all doing great and
today i want to talk about something
that has been on my mind for quite some
time and it's based on many messages i
get from you on instagram on linkedin on
all the socials and i think that this is
really something where many of you just
have a mindset problem i think very
frankly right i think many of you are
getting this wrong so it's going to be a
little bit like a real talk format a
little bit of a rant maybe so i hope you
can apologize me for doing that but i
trust it's going to be fine okay and the
issue that i have what many of you are
doing is that you're writing messages
saying things like oh i want to join
consulting what do i need to do i'm
still maybe even a high school student
and i just want to do everything to get
into consigning what do i need to study
what extracurriculars do i need to do
or also another thing that i get very
regularly is people who are already in
their careers for a couple of years
maybe you work in big four maybe an
industry maybe somewhere else and then i
get messages saying i want to get into
mckinsey into bcg into bain
i want to do an mba or should i do an
mba to get into these firms is this what
will get me in right and then what
program do i need to do
where do i need to study and so on to
fulfill this goal and i think there are
many problems with this type of mindset
and type of attitude because i think the
reality is just especially if you have
the goal to go into firms like mckinsey
bcg bain i mean just stay with that
these are three firms three firms and i
know that of course they're quite
prestigious i know that many people want
to get into them and of course i think
there are good reasons for that and of
course on my channel i talk about many
of these reasons
but there can be so many reasons
why even if you make it into the
interviews you then do not get in surely
this i would argue quite a high rate of
for its negatives right so people who
probably would have deserved to get in
but just didn't make it through the
process maybe because they didn't have
the best day maybe the chemistry with
the one or the other interviewer didn't
work out well there are things that you
cannot always influence right and you
need to live with that that's life
so but if this is what's happening
how can you think that it's a good idea
to just structure your whole life your
whole adolescence your whole twenties
around getting into these three firms
frankly i think that's a little bit
childish frankly i do not think it makes
a lot of sense i do not think that this
is a smart decision to do right and
let's further deep dive into that
because of course there are lots of
decisions that are attached to that and
it starts already in your undergrad
you're asking yourself what degree
should i study to get into mbb get into
mckinsey bcg bane i mean come on this
shouldn't be the only reason right so
you pick a degree subject only for that
but then what if you happen if you
realize that you don't get in then all
these years were wasted how does that
make sense and even if you do make it if
you do get in it's just the truth that
on average a consultant probably stays
for
two three four years at any of these
firms so for such a short amount of time
you want to make these important
decisions again i do not think this
makes sense next step for the mba
people are considering this at least the
impression that i get from many of your
messages people are considering to do an
mba
to spend often a six-digit amount of
money in tuition in living costs and
foregone salary just to get into mbb or
to hope to get into mbb because what
happens
if you then don't get in the end and
frankly while of course i hope that
everyone who does an mba also fulfills
these goals and i do think that doing an
mba might be a great avenue into these
career paths i also just know from my
personal experience having done the mba
at insead that there are many people who
hoped to get into this level of mbb
consulting and then for different
reasons didn't make it
was it then all for nothing did you just
spend all this money all this time
for not meeting your goals is this
really how you want to think about your
life
i really think this is not
a healthy way to look at these types of
things it's not a mature way i would say
it's a little bit childish frankly
and i think it's absolutely fair to say
you have a goal that you want to get
into consulting that you'd love to also
get into mbb consulting and yes i would
argue probably there is a difference
between tier one tier two tier three
consulting firms
but surely you shouldn't obsess
around this being your only goal you
shouldn't plan your whole life around
that right and of course many things you
do that will help you to potentially get
into mbb will also help you to get into
other attractive career paths so it's
about your gpa the grades if you write
good grades a strong gpa of course this
will help you in other things as well if
you work on extracurriculars and so on
but don't do things only because you
hope that this will help you to do it
you shouldn't do an mba if your only
objective is to get into mbb because
chances are at the end of the day quite
high that you won't make it
so let's talk about some other things
that you could do that are very
attractive
a couple of ideas maybe also for you if
you really feel like the only way for
you to have a great career in management
and general management is to do mckinsey
bcg bane what else could you do what
might be great alternatives
first idea
found a startup i have actually many
people i personally studied with in my
time here at university of munich that
instead of starting a career in mckinsey
bcg band and tier one consulting they
founded a startup and now have unicorns
and probably it was a golden time
especially also in the last years but
again several people i studied with whom
were in my semester in my cohort who
founded now today unicorns and surely
these people
do not regret to have not joined mbb in
the end right and of course not everyone
makes it survivorship buyers many people
who started startups who didn't do it
but i think in the end of the day it's
much more realistic much more possible
than maybe you think
first point
second point if you maybe you feel like
it's too much risk to do that to start
your own startup
join such a startup join such a young
company
right so already join a starter that is
already established i think the sweet
spot probably is to join a company
that just raised a serious a right so
that just raised a big substantial
financing round because of what this
means is that the company already does
show some level of traction does at
least show initial signs of product
market fit so you take out a lot of the
initial risk of joining such a company
you are in a situation where the company
now raised significant amounts of money
good serious a rounds today are often 10
20 30 40 million dollar if you look at
the last valuations the current numbers
so these are often environments where
lots of people get hired where you might
suddenly be in a position even as a
junior person who is doing a good job to
only after a short amount of time you
become a team lead you become lots of
responsibility
and i think people also severely
underestimate the salaries that you can
earn in these type of roads frankly i
think in these environments for these
fast hyper growth type of companies you
can often earn salaries absolutely
equivalent to people being consultants
senior consultants even project leads in
consulting type of environments
and often of course the lifestyle is
significantly better than what you can
expect at mckinsey bcg bain and frankly
if you would be interested in an
opportunity like that we have currently
a row like that at my current employer
at my current company building radar as
well we are looking for a role that we
call
a revenue engineer so building radar is
doing something that is called revenue
engineering we are helping industry and
construction companies to digitalize and
fuel their sales in commercial processes
and we are hiring at the moment for this
one specific role it will be a role that
very closely works together with us as a
sea level so me including with the board
of building raider with the managing
directors of building radar it is a role
where you will work closely together
with some of our largest customers with
senior leadership of large industry
players in germany and in europe and it
is a position where you can have a
significant influence on the strategic
direction of our young company
so if this would be something that you
would be interested in i will leave a
link to this job posting in the video
description check it out
two requirements though first you need
to be based in munich
so it's not a fully remote position and
second you need to be fluent both in
english and in german but if you meet
these requirements
you can apply via the link in the video
description just also write in your
cover letter that you saw this video and
then i will also have the opportunity to
look at your application as well and
frankly i think another benefit of
joining such a position in a young
company is that i think there's no
better preparation to eventually found
your own startup if you maybe don't want
to do it right away out of university or
with a couple of years of work
experience there's no better way than
having worked for such a young growth
company because all the things that you
see that you learn with working together
closely with the management team with
the founders these will be exactly the
learnings that will help you to then
start your own venture as well raise
capital raise money and bring that to
life
and then the third overarching
opportunity that i see as an alternative
to what you can do in consulting is
b2b sales this is also something that i
learned over the last years i think it's
absolutely crazy the careers that people
have who work as an account executive as
a key account manager for any of these
b2b sales companies here behind us
actually there's the office of
salesforce here in munich if you are an
account executive at a company like
salesforce and that's just one of many
examples so any of these
sas companies and again including
building radar because we are a sas
company as well
the people there can earn
easily six digit salaries
it's just a great career sales lots of
opportunities also lots of growth
potentials that you see so if working
together with b2b customers if working
together um with other people
selling products in the b2b environment
is something you're interested in think
about pursuing such a career in sales
because the truth is salaries are
probably
rather comparable to what you can expect
in the first three to five years in
consulting
plus the work-life balance is
significantly better to what you can
expect in consulting and again than from
such a safe leadership position that you
will be eventually in this of course is
surely also great then development step
point to then also move into other areas
into other leadership positions of the
company overall and then potentially of
course also starting your own business
in the end
so hope this makes sense to you yes i am
still and i will continue to be a big
proponent of consulting i think it is a
great start your career i think spending
a few years at mckinsey bcg any of these
companies
rarely you did anything back to anyone
right so i think really it's of course a
great opportunity but don't get stuck up
on joining of these firms think in
alternatives thinking options that you
have
don't develop your profile too closely
too narrowly towards such a thing which
then maybe might work out or might not
work out for you in the end and again in
any ways for almost all people there
will be a career after consulting only
very few people stay there until the
partner roll it's very unlikely that you
will do that as well and that alone
should be reason enough for you to then
find your own position find your own
path
so thank you this is just what i wanted
to talk about today appreciate your time
if you like this as always hit the like
button turn on the subscriber they'll
turn on the notification bell
big thanks to the members of the channel
very much appreciate your support see
you again next week my name is heinrich
i'm a former mckinsey consultant
releasing career advice here on my
channel from learning new videos every
single saturday all the best to you and
bye